it's 1960 and look how happy sharon and
karen and joey are and bob has
completely forgotten the horrors of the
second world war
they are happy because of this glass
door
but to understand doors like the ones
sold here you have to go to the patent
application you know what we'll get back
to that cue the penguins
because when admiral richard byrd went
to antarctica in 1939 science news
reported that he adorned his lab with
non-frosting window panes
and newspapers around the country shared
the picture but this technology had a
far greater impact than helping arctic
researchers study cute penguins a new
type of window enabled everything from
paradisal patios to a change in
skyscrapers from ones that look like
this to ones that look like this and in
this case the breakthrough had a name
thermapain
changed bob's world
[Music]
i was just curious what attracted you to
write about this and research this topic
when i've told people oh yeah i'm doing
a research project on insulated glass
you know the response is always like you
know what the reality is that you know
it changed the way that we did building
enclosures radically and in a very very
short period of time
the way that building interiors were
illuminated for hundreds thousands of
years was
natural daylight or you had to burn
something basically to be able to see
and sign tonight when electricity came
along in the 1870s 1880s that changes
the formula but not all the way right
electricity is still expensive for
decades and so you still have these very
very large windows to bring daylight
especially into offices one thing i was
reminded of i did this one little series
on old movie studios like in the silent
era and before they really got the
lighting down
it's exactly what you're talking about
because they all look like greenhouses
because they just have to
adapt to this situation
of not being able to have powerful
enough light that affects the
architect's
aesthetic at the time is is what you're
saying but there's a real environmental
penalty there because the glass is a
pretty good insulator but the problem is
that it has to be so thin to see through
that you lose all of the heat
in the building during the winter or you
pick it all up in the summer so glass is
both necessary but also a problem as
electricity got cheaper and more places
started using heating and air
conditioning large windows kind of went
out of style in 1931 the chicago tribune
wrote about architects laughing at the
idea of glass walls they were not
feasible because glass was a great
conductor of heat and cold but people
still wanted to see outside glass blocks
like these were one solution they
insulated well as a plus they offered
privacy but you couldn't see out of them
clearly like real windows
so there has to be a wall between bob
and his children
[Music]
instead of watching them play he's
forced to ponder the unspeakable things
he did during the war
[Music]
but in 1934 libya owens ford glass
company announced a new glass process
they acquired from a refrigeration
engineer in milwaukee this engineer
realizes that if you can double the the
glass right and between those two layers
of glass
take out all of the humid air and
replace it with dried air air with all
the water taken out you can get not only
the insulating value of the two pieces
of glass that thin layer of air in
between does a really really good job of
preventing
heat from jumping from one pane of glass
to the next builders are chasing
something called r-value it's a measure
of insulation higher equals more
insulation that pink insulation in your
wall it might have a really high r value
a pane of glass is down at one thermo
pain doubled that at more than two and
it was still transparent newspapers
reported that they extended the line and
soon that double pane glass was down in
antarctica and thermapen salesman
reclaiming admiral byrd said it kept his
lab 75 degrees fahrenheit behind the
windows though the seal required some
reworking over the next decade
thermapain changed the possibilities for
architects thermo pain gets going but
then
competitors do start up pretty quickly
so it becomes a competitive marketplace
for this type of dual system pittsburgh
plate glass which is one of their big
competitors comes up with a slightly
different way of doing it and so they
patent that and they market it as uh as
twindom
because it has two layers of glass i
would say by the 1960s if you're if
you're putting a big window into any
residential or office building other
than you know very very separate climate
you're probably just doing insulated
glass almost by default
today you can find triple pane windows
and thin glass coatings like low e-glass
that have advanced the same idea they
can bump up that r value to above three
at the same time builders worry about
all the glass walls we'll need to
replace often from seals that are
breaking down but the thermapen
revolution really did change how people
work and live
[Music]
the residential advertising for this is
always a sliding glass door looking out
onto very verdant landscape
which is basically saying you know
here's a way of connecting your inside
world and your outside world i noticed
this blanket of air phrase a couple of
times
even though it's it's very very broad
wide open glass window here is cuddled
up in a blanket the family at home is
enjoying the convenience and the
functional beauty of walls of glass
merging room with room
blending inside with outside taking away
the barrier between the inside the
outside is kind of socially and
culturally what a lot of these
mid-century modern homes were all about
being able to see all of your stuff
therma pain was a way to stop staring at
the past
and start seeing the future
i guess this is by pittsburgh plate
glass company too is that kind of a
different category spandel usually
refers to the solid panel between the
the transparent ones and it it does two
things it covers up the edge of the
floor plate which is usually you know
thick and
kind of floppy concrete
um but for a long time and this is a
whole other rabbit hole but but for a
long time these glass curtain walls
are running a foul of
kind of old-fashioned fire codes
that say we need to have a three-foot
usually foot brick wall
between one window and the next
and so the way they got around that like
behind the dark green
panels in this building there's probably
a brick wall
but they're putting a piece of opaque
glass in front of it
to give you the
illusion of an all-glass
facade
right which was
surprisingly like a fairly common common
thing